what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven a prediction video this is going
to be a special video that I make them
for all of you kind people that have
donated to this channel by joining me
over on patreon since you go above and
beyond to support this channel I wanted
to make a video answering some of the
questions that you had so let's get
right into it
Carrie asked do you think that the three
heads of the Dragon metaphoric or
otherwise could possibly be the night
king who has ice
Daenerys who is fire and Jon Snow who is
both thank you for the question Carrie
but in my opinion I do not think the
night King has anything to do with that
prophecy but I do like the way you
worded this with Danny being fire the
night king being ice and John being both
that does make the question more
intriguing but in my opinion if there
are going to be three heads of the
Dragon or even three Dragon Riders I
believe they all have to be Targaryen or
have the blood of a dragon I should say
since the night King is a stark I do not
think he falls into that prophecy but
that doesn't mean he will never take a
dragon as we all know from the past
these dragons may seem unstoppable right
now but they can be killed and by the
end of the series and by the end of this
story I think some of them if not all of
them will be killed
another question Carrie asked she said a
lot of the characters have been left out
of the show but they made room for your
on is this simply to have a third act
villain now that Ramsay is dead or do
you think that he might have a larger
role to play in the final battle I think
the answer for this is yes and no they
do need another villainous type
character although they do have Cersei
in the night king who both seem to be
causing a hell of a lot of havoc right
now but you're on will play that role as
well you might not be around until the
very end but I think he will make a huge
impact to this season that causes a
shift in Westeros his role is also going
to depend on how much they actually
adapt from the books to his character in
the books he is said to have a dragon
horn an armor made out of Valyrian steel
those are two huge game-changing things
he could potentially have in the show
which would completely change everything
but obviously Euron didn't have the
dragon horn with him at the Kings move
which is where he should have presented
it but maybe just maybe he provides this
offering to Sir
see imagine if someone had a weapon to
take a dragon and control that dragon
imagine how much it would change things
and if you're on has his full suit of
armor made out of Valyrian steel imagine
how useful that would be not only could
you wear the Valyrian steel armor
fighting the white walkers but you could
also melt it down and make it into a
shitload of weapons depending what Dan
and Dave wrote in to the show for his
character
I think Euron could play a significant
role but it's hard to say what he will
actually have with him I'm hoping he
lives up to his potential from the books
but I guess we're going to have to wait
and see Brienne also asked a couple
questions which I really do appreciate
the first question is if we are to know
all there is to know about Robert's
rebellion by the end of the series what
will we see okay just to kind of clarify
this for people who may not know george
RR martin made a post on his not a blog
recently and he said HBO hired five
writers so they could create five
different pilots in hopes of a new show
getting picked up after Game of Thrones
ends George said Robert's rebellion will
not be chosen as a spin-off series
because he said when he finishes his
story we will already know everything
about the events that took place during
that time so to answer your question
Brienne when George said that he was
actually talking about the books he said
when he finishes his story we would know
everything he didn't necessarily say the
television show would reveal it I think
he meant his books but I do believe we
will see a few things that took place in
this time period before the series ends
we could possibly get a quick scene of
the battle at the Trident or we could
see Rhaegar and Lyanna getting married
if they did in fact get married or we
could get another Tower of joy scene but
this time we could see Rhaegar and
Lyanna together that way John's father
is visually confirmed bran will be
harnessing his powers this season so the
possibilities are endless Brienne also
asked once the night Kings army reaches
the wall does that mean the wildlings
north of the wall were extinct the
Giants the children of the forest other
northern creatures you know north of the
wall in my opinion yes in the television
show I think that has more or less
already happened most of the people
north of the wall were killed at
hardhome
John was only able to save a few
thousand of them and all the children of
the forest
that we saw north of the wall were
killed at the three-eyed Ravens cave and
all the Giants we saw in the show are
now dead as well man 2 did say one of
the Giants was the last one in his
bloodline but this also doesn't mean it
was everyone north of the wall because
we don't know how many children of the
forest were actually up there
tormund also told Jon that most of the
wildlings were at hardhome
he didn't say all of the wildlings were
at hardhome he said most of them were
there so there is a strong possibility
there could be more people still north
of the wall but I think when the night
team comes to the wall I think that
means everyone else that could be up
there is dead when the night king comes
to the wall that will be because there's
nothing left up there for him he has
already cut off from getting more of
Craster's babies and once all the humans
and other species are dead up there he
will have nothing left to add to his
army leaving him with no choice but to
come south everything and everyone will
be dead north of the wall when the night
king reaches it the indie sports core
podcast asks what percentage in your
opinion of how accurate the plot leaked
really is to what we'll see in all seven
episodes this season I'm not going to
read anything from the plot leaked in
this video but I will say that I think
the plot leaked is insanely accurate I
think the plot leaked is 75 percent
accurate at least and if you have read
the plot leaked and you have stayed up
to date with all the spoilers and promos
and trailers and etc then you know the
plot leak has already been proven to be
at least fifty percent right just by
watching the trailers if you've read the
plot League then you know most of it is
right and if you don't think so you are
just in denial and you don't want to
accept the fact that it got most of the
stuff right but I do not think all of it
is right I think dan and Dave did make
some changes after it was leaked but
they couldn't go back and change
everything because it would take too
long and cost too much money when the
leak came out they were just starting to
film so there was only so much that they
could actually change because we had
already scouted the locations they got
permits to film on those locations and
so on and so forth some stuff was set in
stone no matter what and I know there
are still people out there who say the
person that broke this plot leaked just
copied it from the photos that were
already leaked but that is not true when
the plot we came out there was only a
handful of photos that were leaked from
the set and those photos didn't show
them doing anything they were
just standing around the trailers most
of the photos came out months after it
had been leaked Paris oka asked history
likes to repeat is Cersei already in Mad
Queen and will Jaime kill her just like
he did before with the Targaryen king or
maybe Daenerys after losing some fights
will become more and more desperate and
lose her mind looking back at the
Targaryen history there is a high
possibility for mental illness because
of incest in my opinion the answer is
yes I think Cersei has already taken
things a step further than the Mad King
did we know he wanted to burn them all
in burn King's Landing over Cersei
didn't blow up all of King's Landing she
did already proved the lengths she is
willing to go to in order to take out
her enemies and I think we can all
assume that she may do this again we are
going to see Cersei spiral out of even
more control as the show continues on
which will leaves someone with no choice
but to end her life
Jaime is definitely a taut candidate to
be the one to choke the life from Cersei
and what Daenerys I think there is also
a good chance we can see that with her -
I think if Daenerys starts to lose any
of her dragons we will see her good on a
darker path possibly even go on a
rampage we did see the Great Hall in
ruins during her vision at the house of
the undying there was a good chance
Daenerys decides to burn the city to the
ground herself since there are only
holes in the roof that must mean it was
damaged from above most likely by a
dragon if this was caused by a wildfire
it would have completely destroyed the
whole building like we saw with the
septa bail or bran also had a vision of
dragons flying over King's Landing and I
won't be surprised if Daenerys takes the
burned Amal approach either anything is
possible so I wouldn't rule anything out
Martin Brooks asked as we have seen so
far the story arcs between the books and
the TV series have not always been in
conjunction so do you or the panel
foresee a situation where the producers
of the TV series actually take a huge
leap off the storylines and come up with
something entirely new
absolutely Martin just like you said we
have already seen this happen in the
past on multiple occasions and it will
definitely continue to happen Dan and
Dave may know how George intends to end
his story but they don't know everything
else so in order to get to that ending
they are making
it up as they go along we're going to
see deaths reunions and big battles that
won't necessarily ever happen in the
books teyla says I don't think it will
play a role in the show but gillies baby
was switched in the book with the
king-beyond-the-wall 'as baby does
babysan have anything to do with the
night King also Rob's baby is alive in
the books but of course not in the show
just been wondering I know your videos
are on the show so I don't expect a
video but your thoughts would be
appreciated in my opinion gillies baby
100% has something to do with the night
king gillies baby should be a white
Walker right now the baby was not meant
to leave the North without becoming a
white Walker that was not part of the
deal Craster had made what the night
came I'm not sure how that deal was made
or everything that it entails but Gilly
and that baby are still around for a
reason look at all the other
relationships that have taken place in
the show basically every single person
that was in a relationship is now dead
or on very bad terms but Sam and Gilly
are still together stronger than ever
Gillian that baby would not still be
alive if they didn't have a role to play
time would not be wasted on them just so
Sam can have a girlfriend
Gilly is with Sam because Sam has the
connection with Jon and the wall and we
all know Jon will have another encounter
with the night king Gillian the baby
being with Sam keeps them involved in
the story and the show without ever
having to focus on just them they are
there in the background but the baby
will come to the forefront at some time
I can't remember where I heard this
quote but it said the reason why the
White Walkers started to wear armor in
the show was because Sam was able to
kill the white Walker when he came for
the baby after Sam stabbed the white
Walker they started to wear armor and it
all stems back to the night king wanting
that baby there is going to be some
consequences for that without a doubt
there is one more question I will answer
but I will get out of here so I don't
take up too much of your time today
Dennis Chadwick asked me if I have ever
made a video about all the different
relationships love interests past and
current sisters brothers etc that are on
the show and how they are all connected
I have not made a video like that Dennis
I have made a few different
marriage her wedding type videos before
but nothing like that specifically but
since you are such a big supporter of
mine I did make a note about this for
future reference that way I can look
into this a little bit more for you
thank you very much Dennis I also want
to thank you all for stopping by today
and supporting this video I really
appreciate that we are only six days
away from the premiere of season 7
episode 1 I'm getting pretty damn
excited at this point I hope you all are
as ready as I am there should be a lot
of fun I also got a ton of equipment
showing up on my house in the next few
days I have plans to make all kinds of
different videos during the season you
might even see me on camera soon doing
some reactions and live streams so I
hope you all show me some mercy when you
finally see me on camera I'm pretty
excited for that as well before I go I
want to give a huge shout out to my
patreon supporters without your help I
would not have been able to buy all this
new stuff that I have come into the
house you all will actually be a big
reason why I am able to produce my
videos with the higher quality this
season and I cannot thank you enough for
that I hope everyone has a good day I
love you all and I'll see you down in
the comment section bye